RNA strong we are stronger economically
than we have been in history
the show continues and I'm here to tell
you all about it I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's March 14 2023
I've got a fresh short haircut we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals and before we do anything else
today yesterday we did our special 3 P.M
show yesterday because I was at that
diversity equity and inclusion event up
in West Palm with Governor DeSantis so
we did a delayed show and during the
show I referenced Yolanda Vega and
several of you did not know who Yolanda
Vega was but Yolanda Vega was a huge
television star if you lived in the
tri-state area in the 80s 90s and even
in the last 20 years apparently I'm told
she just retired last year she was the
lottery woman
and people were going Dave who is this
Yolanda Vega and why do you say it like
that we put together a little
compilation of Yolanda Vega's best
moments enjoy
welcome yes I am Yolanda Vega evening
everyone for the New York Lottery I'm
Yolanda Vega Welcome to the New York
Millennium Millions drawing being held
live in Singapore
now here's tonight's number the first
fall good evening I'm Yolanda Vega hello
good evening I'm Yolanda Vega
and I'll have what she's having what a
what a life Yolanda I hope you enjoy
retirement uh little known fact about
Yolanda Vega she was the most
controversial woman in America from the
80s uh well into the mid-2000s that's
how good we used to have it it was
before all this woke BS a woman like
that would be controversial anyway if
you want to join us for the post game
show as always join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and real quick
speaking of locals I don't know if you
guys heard about this but Scott Adams
you guys know Scott Adams he's been on
the show many times uh and he's a great
thinker and author and creator of the
Dilbert comic uh he got into some hot
water over some comments that he said
that were completely misconstrued I'm
not even going to get into the details
of that but Dilbert which has been in
virtually every newspaper in America as
a comic strip for the last I don't know
three decades at least something like
that it basically has been absolutely
canceled everywhere and he's moving the
entire thing uh to locals so not only
did we get Crowder last week on Rumble
we've got Scott on locals and we got
Russell Brand and we really are building
those pipes and I'm feeling good about
that I'm also feeling good and this is
what the show is about today about the
crop of Republicans who are starting to
get into the mix there's going to be
some tussling there's going to be some
back and forth but we are going to see a
really solid interesting and politically
diverse group of people going for that
Republican nomination of course that
will be to the backdrop of all of the
insanity that we're dealing with right
now whether it's the woke stuff or this
craziness now with bank bailouts or
where the economy is going to be in a
year
etc etc but people are starting to get
involved they're starting to announce
that they're going to get into The Fray
and there are a couple people who we
suspect will announce who haven't quite
gotten in yet but all of the the energy
seems to be focused on one guy who has
not got in yet he happens to be the guy
I was with yesterday morning the
governor of the Free State of Florida
Ron DeSantis and we're going to contrast
a bunch of the political positions of
some of the other people running
obviously you got Trump now you have
Vivek Rama Swami you have Nikki Haley a
couple other people it sounds like Pence
is about to jump in uh and uh we're
gonna compare and contrast some of their
views and really talk about who can
actually bring new voters in because
that's what it's about right like the
Republicans did not win last time Trump
says it was it was fixed but whether it
was fixed or not
he we sort of know what he can do the
question is who can actually bring in
new people and get us to this new
political realignment that I think is
just staring Us in the face and actually
could get us out of all of this madness
that is the plan today and before we get
to it let me talk to you about balance
of Nature real quick you know nothing is
more fundamental than the fact that
fruits and vegetables are good for you
did you know that but eating all the
fruits and vegetables you need can be
time consuming and expensive that's why
I take balance of nature it gives me a
foundation of nutrition and the positive
effects of a wide variety of fruits and
vegetables in just a few seconds see my
hundreds of thousands of people take
balance of nature every day get 35
percent off your first preferred order
when you use discount code Dave that's
35 off your first preferred order when
you use discount code Dave and now back
to me that was a short one all right so
when we talk about these crossover
people what you guys know I'm always
focused on
is the decent lives because there are
decent lips they're not in the Democrat
Party that's in Washington DC they're
all lunatic progressives or scared of
their own shadow or fold quicker than a
wet paper bag types but your aunt who
thinks that these are the Democrats of
1986 right like there are these people
who maybe can move a lot of them seem to
have this aversion to Trump no matter
what right like I could maybe vote for a
republican but I can't vote for Trump
now I may think that's unjust and I
gladly voted for Trump and there's a
situation in which I might vote for him
again depending on how it all shakes out
but the group of people who I think are
most likely to move are the disaffected
libs right that's probably many of you
guys and many of you I think have
probably shifted accordingly right
everyone in the room that I'm in right
now is the first time uh Republican
registered voter here in the Free State
of Florida well one of those people I
talk about him every now and again uh is
Bill Maher and Bill as much as I try to
push and pull and prod every time he
takes two steps forward he unfortunately
seems to take three steps backwards uh
here he is on Real Time a couple days
ago talking about DeSantis and and I
think he is just missing the freaking
point
disagree with that first of all
everything I hear about DeSantis is that
he's dull he doesn't have any Charisma
and also I think I think liberals they
just they they make a real effort not to
understand the Trump voter and um you
know it's like oh just dance is going to
be great because he's it's trumpism
without Trump and I think they're like
why would we want a tribute band
when the actual band is still playing
Bill Bill I'm going to keep working on
you and I'm going to text you after the
show to so you know that this isn't
going after you personally I just want
to get you there but a couple things uh
first off this thing about DeSantis
being dull I mean I've I've hung out
with him a bunch and been to events with
him and had a drink with him multiple
times and smoke cigars with him I don't
even like smoking cigars he's totally a
decent guy he's a fun guy he's a cool
dude he's a normal human being that's
the weird thing of him being involved in
politics right he's got a couple kids
he's got a wonderful wife like he's a
decent guy he's a policy wonk for sure
and is he the most television game show
ready president we've ever had probably
not but we had that with Trump and I
don't think you guys like Trump that
often and more importantly than any of
that look what the guy gets done he took
away Disney's special privileges he did
the quote-unquote don't say gay thing I
actually said the word gay to him
yesterday he did not attack me punch me
or have his goons remember move me we're
getting child mutilation genital
mutilation out of our entire State like
they're going to take away people's
doctor's licenses on this stuff he's not
going to force people to be masked we
were the first to fight mandates on on
all the vaccine nonsense we have family
first tax relief right near here we have
a huge huge budget surplus we had a
absolutely massive basically category
five storm Crush Southwest Florida and
we have rebuilt faster than would be
completely imaginable so Mar is wrong
he's wrong about his character he's
wrong about the presentation uh but he's
right in that the Trump without Trump
argument is shallow in some sense it is
I think what most people on the right
are beginning to realize is actually the
opposite of that that DeSantis is Trump
meaning he has some of the same ideas
except he's much more of a threat
because he can get things done and
unfortunately that's why Mar fears him
Mar I suspect because Mar does not want
want to and and the the last Libs many
of them the public ones the last thing
they want to do is at the end go all
right but I do have to vote for
Republicans so they'd rather
they'd rather the nominee be Trump that
that is what you're going to see over
the next year you're going to see MSNBC
even pushing Trump in a weird way
because they know that if it's Trump
then it's very easy to be like the
Republicans are all nuts I didn't vote
for Donald Trump last time Donald Trump
is evil he's orange Hitler blah blah
blah we're DeSantis it's going to be
much more nuanced DeSantis all the
santis is going to have to do basically
is get up on the debate stage all the
time and be like look how many people
moved into our state and look how many
people left California we set every
record related to tourism we have
all-time low crime all-time low
unemployment blah blah blah he doesn't
have to get involved in all of that
stuff and he doesn't have to be a game
show host so the policy positions in
many ways
are are a sharper version of trump stuff
but they're getting executed and they're
incredibly popular at the moment and
this is all to the backdrop of the guy
has not announced and I tried in my own
very subtle way yesterday when we were
sitting down to get a little hint but I
did not get it but you can see everybody
whether it's MSNBC or Trump is attacking
DeSantis right now so that tells you
where the energy is here is a video
Trump put this up yesterday going after
DeSantis and again I like Trump I want
to interview him again I like the kids
but listen to this and tell me the
nicknames and the nonsensical argument
he's making here does any of this make
any sense to you and do you think this
is Trump at his best
for those of you that didn't notice
Florida was doing great long before
Rhonda Sanctus got there people are
fleeing from New York to Florida and
other places
because of high taxes and out of control
crime it's really bad not because of the
governor thank you Mr President for
doing that
but it's not because of the governor
Florida was doing fantastically you had
a governor named Rick Scott who did a
very good job even Charlie Chris the
Democrat did a good job and he had very
good numbers
sunshine and ocean are very alluring
it's not too hard to work with those
factors
so just remember Florida was doing
really well long before Iran to Sanctus
got there
there's so much here I'm so tired of
this nonsense it's like let me just say
first off Trump again I like you I like
you so if you want to really do this you
just have to level up but this is just a
whole load of nonsense first off Ron
just sank this do you know what Sanctus
means in Latin it means holy okay so I
think you uh failed with that one Trump
and sanctimonious didn't work and okay
the nickname thing it's just not gonna
work because the guy's getting stuff
done it works when you can sort of
needle people on these things it's just
not working on that front uh he's
talking about Charlie Chris there
Charlie Chris just lost by 20 points in
the biggest political destruction really
in modern well certainly in modern times
in Florida but really almost across the
country like Blown Away Charlie Crist
was also a republican Trump is
referencing him as Governor he was
governor he what was it like 15 years
ago he was a republican at the time so
Trump is suddenly into rhinos Or
democrats because Charlie Chris became a
Democrat also so uh Rhonda santis
he did do something right which is why
all the people are moving here and we
still get 1200 people a day and AOC and
Eric swalwell and Don Lemon are
vacationing in Florida while they spend
all day long on TV bashing Florida right
so it's just very very bizarre and I
just don't think it works if you want to
beat the guy you have to say these are
why my policies are better but I think
one of the things that Trump is coming
up against is the fact that DeSantis is
actually at the state level doing many
of the things that Trump either said he
was going to do or promise to do and and
just hasn't been able to do really
because he's not in office right now so
here's uh is this we're going with Trump
first yeah
so here is Trump calling for the
immediate defunding of critical race
Theory uh all the trans stuff and
sexualization in schools does this sound
kind of familiar was there some guy in a
rather warm State having something to do
with alligators who did a little bit of
that take a look
I will immediately sign a new executive
order to cut Federal funding for any
school
that's pushing critical race Theory
transgender insanity
thank you
and any other inappropriate racial
sexual or political content on our
children their children
the good part that's great to hear and
he is a candidate and you want as many
good candidates pushing the right ideas
so cutting funding for schools that are
promoting racial essentialism that are
pushing sexuality and all this other
nonsense on kids great uh but he's going
after DeSantis relentlessly now the guy
who is literally doing it here in
Florida he has been the tip of the spear
on this stuff also you know Trump could
have campaigned on these type of things
from 2015 to 2020 right he could have he
could have Now Grant him a leash on the
2015 thing because it was sort of early
on in the wokeness and everyone was kind
of figuring it out but he what really
wasn't running on it in the last
campaign DeSantis saw it very clearly
and saw also really how it was connected
uh to so many of the broader issues in
society and he has gone out of his way
now with the Republican super majority
in Florida to get rid of all of this
stuff when Trump's saying we want to get
the racial stuff out of the schools what
he's talking about is DeSantis getting
rid of the African-American AP studies
course as you guys know about that they
stuck woke gender theory in right so
there you go uh but if you don't believe
me Dave what are you talking about
really could you play a video of
DeSantis saying he's done those things
and we'll continue to do those things
okay fine here you go
these are not private institutions
they're public institutions and we have
the right uh who are elected and who are
putting people in positions to make sure
that those institutions are serving a
mission that is consistent with the
state's best interests and so as this
has become a problem I ask to get more
information about it we got them
reporting how much money they're
spending on it we introduce legislation
to remedy that and we will be the first
state in these United States to wipe out
Dei at our Public University
[Music]
and we're actually going to do it you
want to throw up the image I took this
picture yesterday this is at the event
that DeSantis held this was a huge uh
digital event really cool Studio that
they have over there in West Palm uh and
you can see some of the academics around
him uh he has thought leaders and
academics he goes around the guy he has
a couple notes in front of him but he
really does a fine job of hosting a
two-hour event they skyped in a bunch of
people including including Chris Ruffo
who you guys know and they go through
how literally how they are going to ban
diversity Equity inclusion in our
schools and our institutions here so
Trump is right of course what Trump said
is right we he's Trump says he wants to
do it by executive action now I don't
love executive actions whether they come
from Republicans Or democrats but if an
executive order if they are going to
exist I'm actually okay with the
president doing it to make sure that
children aren't you know sexualized by
their teachers and the rest of that
stuff but the point is we are doing it
in the functional way here that's why
that's why I've been saying for months
when when the machine really moves on to
santis and you've seen the articles on
this already what they're going to say
is he's Trump with the calculator he's
Hitler with a calculator right because
Trump was Hitler but this guy he can do
it because he's actually he actually
studies the stuff and he knows exactly
what's going on I'll tell you we did
this little sit down with the governor
for about 20 minutes about there were
about five of us uh just an off the
Record sit down
so it was off the record I can't tell
you anything that was said not that it
was not whether it was really anything
that shouldn't be said publicly uh but
one of the things that always impresses
me about him is you asked this guy about
a random City somewhere or district
school district somewhere in Florida he
knows virtually everyone on the school
boards and the superintendents like he
really knows his stuff he is a student
of this he's a policy wonk as I said
that's the thing that Bill Maher is
going oh he's he's kind of stiff and and
you know he's not television ready
something like that and it's like well
maybe we're ready for that maybe with
the group of people that we have in
front of us and Biden with dementia and
the the endless clown car of diversity
hires that this Administration has put
out there to lie about everything maybe
we kind of want a guy who maybe isn't
the life of the party and I'm not even
saying he isn't he's totally cool dude
basically uh but maybe we want someone
that's just competent anyway uh here is
Trump announcing that he will defund any
school that mandates uh vaccines or
masks which I'm fairly certain we've
also done here in the state of Florida
as a vaccine mandate or a masked
Band-Aid
from kindergarten through college
all right well that's uh great again
this is good Trump this is great that's
what we all want it's fantastic you know
and unfortunately I suppose maybe he
could have done more or not given fauci
the leash that he gave or whatever but
we don't need to play Monday Morning
Quarterback on that but here's Governor
DeSantis in October of 22 in the midst
of the cleanup of hurricane Ian talking
about how we were going to make vaccine
mandates and masks and everything all
the other nonsense related to this
illegal right here in Florida
before I leave that you know there's
been a lot of questions uh to our office
about the CDC protected potentially
adding covid vaccine to the childhood
immunization schedule and I know a lot
of parents are concerned about that
because if that's on the immunization
schedule the fear is that schools could
potentially mandate your child to get a
coveted shot even if that's not
something that you want to do so I just
want to let everyone be clear you know
as long as I'm around and as long as I'm
kicking and screaming uh there will be
no covid shot mandates for your kids
that is your decision
in that speech that he was giving right
there we had already done that here in
Florida he was reiterating what had been
done in Florida so again Trump is
repeating a lot of the things that
DeSantis has done that's just fine right
I wouldn't mind if you have 10
candidates right and everybody's looking
at the guy who's actually doing all the
stuff boy that guy's doing a heck of a
job over there I do want to run for
president too and maybe I think I'm
better for this reason that reason the
other reason I'm a better debater
um this on that I have a different idea
on this but if everyone starts emulating
all of the good stuff that is good that
is how you get an actually uh I would
say dense collection of candidates that
it will be worth listening to just try
to go back to the last set of Democrats
that we had up there and you're
listening to Pete bootage and Eric
swalwell and Elizabeth Warren like it
was such a thin group of not smart
people up there and and we had to
pretend that any of these people were
going to be president and then the DNC
just did their little trick and then
they you know just pushed Biden out
there everyone Cuts their deals Pete
says hey can I be Transportation
secretary if I drop out they're like you
got it man I mean that's that is what
they do that politics is a dirty game it
just is what it is uh here's more from
DeSantis here he is calling out Trump's
white house after they lost it basically
when he was opening up Florida during
the pandemic yeah that happened
the the white the white house task force
was hammering me for like the first like
really like three months because they
wanted me to be uh you know clamping
down harder and um and and she you know
she and she was so I called I was like
Deborah just tell me when in American
history monitor has this been done and
what were the results because like I
kind of feel like you know we're Flying
Blind here and we may be doing things
that could be damaging and she said
she's like you know it's kind of our own
science experiment that we're doing in
real time and that didn't sit well with
me I mean you know you're a citizen of a
republic you're not a guinea pig and so
uh what I think that that there's a
whole bunch of other things I talk about
in the book you remember the um George
Floyd Riot yeah epidemiologist because
people are saying you've been telling
people just you have to stay in your
home and like in Florida they were
killing us because even in those early
days you know when we were following
federal guidelines Loosely but we were
filing some we were playing golf I mean
The Villages they're setting record for
golf people are boating all this stuff
they were so mad at Florida doing the
people on the beach all this stuff that
was their position you are killing
people if you leave your house so then
all these people are like thousands of
people are protesting this public health
this public health uh a clan of people
they are sick
is that guy not friendly enough for you
is he not a good enough Communicator for
you or whatever else you might be
thinking like actually that's the type
of person I would want in the office
someone who can actually communicate the
ideas clearly and cogently and
competently and stand up for the right
things what a great line you're a
citizen of a republic not a guinea pig
now the Deborah he's referring to there
obviously is Deborah Burks who Trump let
in charge of a lot of this and in
essence they were saying we don't know
what the hell we're doing just follow
our guidelines so look to Trump's credit
he did at times go out of his way to say
to the states do what you think is best
right and that's what Federalism is all
about that's what limited government's
all about that's what the president is
supposed to do but as DeSantis is laying
out there then they had you know the
agents basically Burks and fauci you
know very upset and Trump ultimately
very upset that Florida was opening up
too quickly there's also that video
we've played it a couple times where uh
Trump was angry that Georgia was opening
up quickly so these these are just facts
and the reason I'm showing them showing
them to you is I think there's a
competency level here that needs to be
really seen I think you guys see it but
it needs to be seen more so because he's
getting things done and in the back in
the day Republicans did not get anything
done you may remember this video from a
couple weeks ago this is on CNBC this is
Mike Pence former VP Mike Pence going
after DeSantis because he beat Disney he
apparently doesn't think that the
government should do anything to take
away special privileges and special
rights and tax exemption uh he just
wants the government to kind of do
nothing which sort of sounds a little
more dare I say uh rhino-ish the guy who
was picked by Trump to be the VP
so we I fully support what Florida did
about protecting kids under the third
grade but I I have concerns about the
follow-on look Disney stepped into The
Fray they lost uh but then
they're taxing Authority you know I that
was that was beyond the scope of what I
as a conservative limited government
Republican would be prepared to do
interesting is why people don't like
Republicans don't you get that uh Pence
don't you get that going after their tax
Authority where does it say that Disney
a giant corporation that makes cartoons
should have their own tax Authority it
doesn't say it anywhere until Florida
gave it to them you know 50 60 years ago
whatever it is all DeSantis did was take
it away he took it away so every
organization and Company incorporation
will play by the same rules and have the
same tax rules and everything else for
some reason Sea World and Gator World
they had to play by the rules everyone
else had to play by Disney didn't and
then Pence looks at evening out the
playing field equality right making it
equal for everybody Pence sees that
doing that as a use of government that
is too big for him I'm a limited
government Republican so I want to get
the government out of the way so we can
privilege certain companies and punish
other companies it actually makes no
sense but that's what the Republicans
have been selling you for a long time
what do I always say you don't have to
be a Democrat you can't be a Democrat
wait what do I always say you you don't
have to be a republican but you can't be
a Democrat my argument on that is I'm
not telling you the Republicans are all
amazing they certainly aren't and they
will usually fail you but maybe you get
a once in a generation type guy with the
right ideas who can get this stuff out
and then it starts exposing the frauds
and I would say in this case Pence is I
will interview Pence I hope I will treat
him with respect and everything else and
I will ask him about just that how can
you say your limited government if what
you mean by that is you are going to
allow for certain government privileges
for certain organizations and just to be
clear on all of this stuff whether you
agree with DeSantis all on all of this
whether you think Trump would affect do
all this stuff more effectively the
simple truth is Trump lost the last
election and DeSantis
destroyed his opponent unit here in
Florida if you remember in 2018 DeSantis
won by 30
000 votes Andrew Gillum was the Democrat
at the time it turned out that the guy
was a meth addict caught at an orgy just
a few weeks I think or maybe two months
after the election and DeSantis only won
by 30 000 votes in 2018. now you can
give Trump some credit for that Trump
did Back to santis so again I'm not here
sitting here to bash Trump as if he
doesn't do anything good that's that's
not what I'm doing at all actually I'll
give Trump credit for helping DeSantis
get over the line but the policy the
point is that after winning by 30 000
votes in 2018 then we get this insane
covid lunacy the lockdowns all of the
stuff and then what happens Florida
becomes the freest state in the Union
and probably the freest place literally
in the entire world and you know what
happens he goes from winning by 30 000
votes to one 0.5 million dollar votes uh
1.5 million votes mathematically
basically 50x his popularity that is
pretty
freaking powerful as is this new ad that
I thought really just nailed it
we find ourselves in Florida on the
front lines in the battle for freedom
together we have made Florida the
nation's most desired destination and we
have produced historic results but now's
not the time to rest on our Laurels we
have the opportunity and indeed the
responsibility the swing for the fences
so that we can ensure Florida remains
number one don't worry about the
chattering class ignore all the
background noise keep the compass set to
True North we will stand strong we will
hold the line we won't back down and I
can promise you this
you ain't seen nothing yet thank you all
God bless you
[Applause]
America that you want to live in isn't
that the America we used to live in I I
am truly not trying to sit here and do
it at Santa's commercial
but sometimes when you get a guy who's
doing it right
who gets the messaging who understands
what the issues are who has the pedigree
as a lawyer and from the Navy and has
surrounded himself with the right people
maybe this is the chance to get out of
the thing I think that might be what
this really is all about this next
election
is this the last chance we have to get
out of the lunacy and and maybe you can
make the argument that Trump is the best
guy to get us out of the ludacity I'm
fairly certain you can make the argument
that the Santos is the best guy to get
us out of the lunacy and someone will
obviously try to make the argument that
that
um Nikki Haley is the best person or
vivec I'm actually going to sit down
with Nikki Haley we're doing that later
this week right uh we're doing that
tomorrow I'm going to sit down with with
Nikki Haley and we will talk about all
of these issues I'm going to try to sit
down in person with all of the
candidates and again treat them all
equally not hiding my opinions you know
the funny thing about mainstream media
you know Chuck Todd pretends he has no
opinions yet it's obvious Jake Tapper et
cetera et cetera I will try to do these
interviews in a far more honest way
again I am not a journalist I am just
some guy with some thoughts and you
watch me Express those thoughts and I'll
sit down with these people and then
you'll make up your mind and it's all
good and if at the end of the day you
watching this right now come to a
different conclusion than me okay we're
good Freedom it's pretty sweet so what
is the mainstream media focused on right
now well they are focused on taking out
to santis it is very obvious note you
say well who's the threat who's the
threat why is no one going after Trump
anymore because they don't view him as
the threat Trump used to Santa said this
as the threat so Trump's going after
DeSantis and everyone on the left is
going after DeSantis and even the sliver
of sane lefties that shouldn't be going
after DeSantis like Mar they're going
after him but on the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC Joy Reed and
as you guys know Joy Reid is a very
well-paid racist crazy person uh here
she is completely lying so this is a
complete lie they talk to you about
misinformation and disinformation they
want us to be banned silenced and
visibility filtered and the rest of it
here's Joy Reid completely falsely
claiming that Republicans want to
prevent black history and the existence
of gays
what does it say about our society that
for one of our two major political
parties the Salient issue for them is
stopping students from learning black
history and from even discussing the
existence of gay people they have
decided that is the most important issue
in the country more than the economy
more than anything else it's stopping
kids from learning those two things
from Candy we don't even need to listen
to his nonsensical answer but she knows
she's lying and what you must understand
is that MSNBC and the executives there
and anyone that puts her on television
they know she's lying too so you have to
know that they put her on television to
lie if anyone at MSNBC had a shred of
journalistic Integrity they would sit
her down and say actually Joy you
joyless Joy Joy it turns out they
they're not trying to stop anyone from
learning black history in Florida it's
actually mandated by the state
repeating myself it's like you guys know
one AP class that had something to do
with gender queer studies that was going
to be incorporated into African-American
history that's what this was about and
that that he doesn't want the existence
of gay people to be known you know it
was funny yesterday so I'm sitting again
we have this little six of us or so five
of us in the governor sitting there and
we're all getting to ask him questions
and we're talking and I start asking him
a couple questions and he full-on didn't
see me he erased my existence I was like
gov can you see me over here dude
it's so silly it's just so absolutely
ridiculous he actually asked me how the
kids are doing so that that's where
we're at with these people they are just
completely absolutely ridiculous uh and
speaking of completely absolutely
ridiculous on the major league channel
that NBC owns because MSNBC is the JV
league for the crazy people and and the
lunatics and the people who've been
caught doing bad things they throw them
over there the major channel is NBC and
Chuck Todd hosts Meet the Press Meet the
Press used to be great Tim Russert was
just absolutely wonderful back in the
day for those of you that remember him
Chuck Todd is a partisan hack who's
who's oh he's just terrible uh anyway
here he is accusing DeSantis of
politicization because we're going to
spend a day a year in Florida schools
teaching about communism and I guess
he's all about communism weird huh
the question I don't know if DeSantis
gonna be talking to swing voters here's
like one of the things he said in Vegas
yesterday take a listen to this
we're also the first state in the
country to establish every November 10th
the day in our schools is earmarked to
teach our students at all grade levels
about the evils of communist regimes
throughout history we're going to tell
the true
ISM in London leninism
it's sort of like look
look a Floridian I sort of know what
he's doing what he's trying to play
there and all of that but I would tell
him I went to Florida Public Schools we
were taught this it was called history
it just seems like a weird politicizing
you know he's going out of his way to
politicize something
first off if Chuck Todd is a Floridian
leave
I mean it Anna Navarro leave all why do
you people live here why do you vacation
here if it is so evil and they're coming
after the gays and they're coming after
the blacks why would you live in such a
place other than you know that
everything you say is a complete lie why
also why this makes literally no sense
why would you be upset that it would be
mandated that we would uh learn that
young people would learn that communism
and Marxism and socialism are bad unless
you're a communist or a Marxist or a
socialist we did a little research here
according to the introduction of the
Black Book of Communism the number of
people killed by Communist governments
is almost a hundred million people about
94 million people these statistics
include victims whose deaths were
through executions man-made hunger
famine war deportations and forced labor
so for some reason Chuck Todd is upset
that people in Florida will know about
that that is quite curious but let's
continue with the lies because the
entire machine is focused on DeSantis
and lying about every single thing that
is happening down here in Florida so
diversity higher Corinne Jean-Pierre she
is our first black lesbian press
secretary she is completely unqualified
she makes gen saki look talented which
that is a talent in and of itself here
she is lying about what the santis is
doing with kids and parents shocker I
know videotape
oh
in Iowa today who said Florida is where
World goes to die
so here's what I have to say
when Republicans
extreme Republicans these Mega
Republicans
don't agree
um with an issue or with policy they
don't bring forth something that's going
to either
have a a good faith conversation they go
to this conversation of woke
but that is not actually policy
but what they what that turns into is
hate what it turns into is Despicable
policy
um and it's just not the way we're going
to move forward
this is not protecting freedoms this is
not having a good faith conversation on
how we can move the country forward this
is about attacking we're talking about
attacking young kids and their parents
because of how they view themselves
no one it's simply not happening you
Corinne Jean-Pierre could come to
Florida you probably vacation on Miami
Beach like the rest of the Democrats
and no one will care about you or your
lesbian wife they might Point At You and
go my God that's Corrine Jean-Pierre
she's a pretty terrible press secretary
but nobody's gonna stop you from going
anywhere because you're black or because
you're a lesbian it's just utter
nonsense and that she dares says that
she's the one that wants to have good
the Democrats yes the Democrats want to
have good faith conversations and that
when you say woke it doesn't translate
into good policy yes it does we're doing
it right here that's why even liberals
bananas California Liberals are moving
to Florida 1200 a day and is it not
Karin Jean-Pierre the Biden Department
of Justice that was trying to treat
parents as domestic terrorists when they
got upset that random School teachers
were talking to their kids about
sexuality and gender and their genitals
yeah that's what the Biden
Administration was doing uh wasn't it
the Biden Administration that forced
parents and kids to take a fake vaccine
and get booster shots and put on masks
and kick them out of schools and
everything else and now we are seeing
all the results of that whether it is
vaccine injuries or whether it is
delayed speech with kids or social
problems or anxiety or whatever else
yeah I think you know I'm right Corinne
Jean-Pierre I'm just trying to have a
good faith argument with you
but it continues it continues Joe Biden
and Joe Biden has no idea what he's
saying he is not in charge of this
operation uh he is completely inept he
is the perfect vessel that's what I
would call Joe Biden at this point he is
a vessel for this stupidity and this
backwards Marxist lunacy because he
doesn't know what he's doing and he's
been in government forever and his wife
has a special place in hell because she
is abusing this man and refuses remember
the video the other day we would never
have a cognitive test we would never do
that like she is this is elderly abused
with this guy but here's Biden calling
out Florida he doesn't like Florida
either because we are going to stop
doctors from giving young children uh
sex hormone blockers and we're not going
to chop off their genitals in the old
days most of us were against genital
mutilation but here we are in modern
times enjoy
transgender kids is a really harder day
thing what's going on in Florida
is as my mother would say close to
sinful I mean it's just terrible what
they're doing it's not like you know a
kid wakes up one morning and says you
know
I decided I want to become a man or I
want to become a woman or I want to
change I mean what what what are they
thinking about here
they're human beings they love they have
feelings they have inclinations that are
I mean it just to me is
I don't know it's cruel and the way we
do it is we make sure we pass
legislation like we passed on same-sex
marriage you mess with that you're
breaking the law and you're going to be
held accountable
sorry you old buffoon we have something
called federalism and the states are
allowed to make whatever laws they don't
like and then if the citizens don't like
those laws they can leave the states but
you don't get to make some sort of law
that's going to override the state when
it comes to genital mutilation Biden
also he looks horrible like this thing
is just breaking down right in front of
us and he simply has no idea what he's
talking about you know when he says that
it also this is what they do with
everything it all kind of sounds right
kids don't just wake up and say I feel
like a man today or feel like a girl or
whatever that does sort of sound right
except it's wrong because we know there
is a social contagion element to this
thing right we know this for a fact when
they're staring all day long at sex
change operations and boys who are girls
and girls or who are boys and boys with
boobs and chicks with dicks and all of
this stuff right when they do see that
all day long on Tick Tock we know now
there's a social contagion element to it
uh Abigail schreier wrote what was
Abigail schreier's book it's a fantastic
book uh irreversible damage thank you
she wrote a fantastic book about this we
should have our on again that young
girls in particular are susceptible to
the the social contagion portion of this
meaning they start seeing these videos
and then they go you know I'm not the
girliest girl ever and actually I like
blue more than I like pink I must be a
boy or what they do the other social
contagion element of of this is they
will take a feminine boy a you know I
don't even like that phrase but a boy
who maybe isn't into just cars and and
Transformers and War and whatever
yeah maybe he likes art or something
else and now they will basically say to
him you are actually a girl so it's odd
because they're the ones who are
actually more into gender stereotypes
but the guy has absolutely know what
he's talked no idea what he's talking
about by the way the interviewer there
was Cal Penn who I guess was a comedian
at one time give me his number what was
his movie he did Harold and Kumar went
to White Castle right somehow he's
interviewing Joe Biden I don't know how
that happened uh but here he is asking
Biden about climate change listen to the
way he phrases this question and what do
I always say you scratch a progressive
you find an authoritarian
you you obviously understand the
existential threat that that young
people feel when it comes to climate
sure how do you balance that with the
immediate concerns of
babysitting Congress or getting getting
51 or 60 votes on some of this well look
um
I've been relative let me be careful
here sure yeah relatively successful
right and working across the aisle
there is a Maga Republican portion of
the party it makes up about a third of
the Republican party but there's a lot
of people in the Republican Party who
are traditional Republic conservative
Republicans that you can deal with but
you know these you know
the gentle woman from the state of
Georgia and the mountains up there and
others Gates and uh anyway it's very
diplomatic I would have used different
language but but no but but if
there's an existential question that the
Republican party is going to have to
face and it's going to determine what
happens in the next couple years but my
focus is just stay focused
focused on the things that matter we've
got to deal with the climate we've got
some of the things that matter what have
they done to that man's forehead what is
going on up here that they have lifted
him so many times he's starting to not
look human but they all right they all
end up this way Pelosi ends up this way
they all end up this way for some reason
okay fine let's put that aside for a
second
um the existential threat young people
face about climate
do you guys uh know any uh you guys are
relatively young in your 20s are your
friends freaking out over climate
everyone everyone okay you're out to
dinner people are talking about other
things and oh my God the climate again
if you think for one second that Joe
Biden or the Democrats or any human on
earth can stop the climate from doing
whatever the hell it wants to do I'd
like to have your head examined we
should study you there's it's just not a
thing I am not worried about climate
change we can try to have green energy
for all sorts of purposes because we
want cleaner air and we want cleaner
water that's an interesting thing to do
if you think this government can bring
you that but even the way he phrases the
question I mean what a heck this kid is
right this cow pen it's like the
existential you people have created a
situation where young people were locked
in their houses where they were forced
on Tick Tock all day where they put
masks on their faces where they were
told that if they're white they're bad
and if they're boys they're mean and
blah blah blah blah blah and now kids
have some anxiety and you're also
like AOC telling us that the Earth is
going to end in seven years but that was
about two years ago and if you think the
Earth is going to end in five years
again it's like man we got to look at
you people and see what's what so these
people are they're just it's all just
endless buffoonery you guys see it and
you must in your own way increase that
visibility for more people it's all just
ridiculous but what's not ridiculous
actually there's a guy over there on Fox
News who's doing some fine work and the
system doesn't seem to like him either
and of course I'm talking about Tucker
Carlson the system has really been
trying to destroy him we played the
video yesterday where Eric swalwell
basically wants to use the power of the
government to force Fox to fire him and
make sure that our troops overseas can't
even watch Fox I mean these people are
completely out of control please show me
where this is happening on the other
side please I'll gladly cover it but it
ain't it just ain't well one of the good
things that Tucker did was he sent out a
letter to many of the people that he
believes are going to run for president
whether it was Donald Trump Ron DeSantis
Mike Pence Vivek Rama Swami et cetera et
cetera he sent out a letter asking what
their policy on Ukraine would be he
wants to and this is what I mean about a
good crop of people who might have
slightly different opinion or or wildly
different opinions when it comes to all
sorts of things Ukraine being one of
them we seem to endlessly be going into
this war where are the Democrats that
used to be anti-war they've all been
silenced why isn't AOC picketing every
day where's ilhan Omar out there against
the war because the Democrats have
become the party of power the party of
War so Tucker sent out this letter to a
bunch of the 2B potential candidates
asking them their policies a
questionnaire on Ukraine I want to read
a couple of the responses because I
think this shows a nice political
diversity uh here's former president
Donald Trump answering the Ukraine
Ukraine questionnaire like inflation and
numerous other self-inflicted wounds and
mistakes made over the past two years
Russia would definitely have not raided
and attacked Ukraine if I was your
president in fact for our four years
they didn't attack nor did they have any
intention of doing so as long as I was
in charge that's a completely you can
come back to me for a second that is a
completely true and clear and cogent
answer by Trump Ukraine what did they do
Russia invaded Ukraine under uh Barack
Obama before Trump right that's we all
know that
nothing happened under Trump we had no
Wars he was trying to scale back things
this is a major place where Trump can
get some credit and and show hey I did
the right things uh as you know they
took Crimea under Obama right is what it
is okay uh let's go to Mike Pence uh
here he is answering the UK Ukraine
questionnaire
like in I'm sorry uh next one Connor
oh sorry it's right sorry I go back to
the previous one yeah there there we go
uh former VP Mike Pence answers our uh
Ukraine questionnaire is opposing Russia
and Ukraine a vital American National
strategic interest that's the question
and here's Pence's answer when the
United States supports Ukraine in their
fight against Putin we follow the Reagan
Doctrine and we support those who fight
our enemies on their Shores so we will
not have to fight them ourselves there
is no room for Putin apologists in the
Republican party now this is super
interesting and this shows you why
Tucker is doing good work that is a huge
huge policy difference between Trump and
Pence now you can agree with either one
of them you can disagree with either one
of them but now we have some information
Trump is saying and this is what he did
by Leading through strength and I've
wrote about this in in don't burn this
book I believe in a strong military so
that we don't have to use it right Trump
led by strength so nobody knew what
Trump was going to do so Russia they
took Crimea under Obama maybe they
wanted this invasion under Trump but
they were like boy that guy's kind of
nuts like is he going to drop a nuke on
us like we don't want that so they
didn't do anything now Pence is taking a
different approach Pence is trying to
connect his approach to Reagan and
basically saying by strong alliances we
will stop the bad guys from encroaching
that might be true it might be but we
know that the thing that Trump did work
so okay this is great now we have some
some contrasting views on foreign policy
within the Republican uh presidential
candidates this is pretty good here's a
Vivek Rama Swami on this and vivec is
obviously not known for his foreign
policy stuff he's known mostly for
financial markets and VCS and funding
and ESG and a bunch more uh here we go
uh is opposing Russia and Ukraine a
vital American National strategic
interest and Vivek says no it is not
vital rather this is a stark reminder of
what is a vital American National
strategic interest National energy
Independence this war is a symptom of a
America's lack of self-sufficiency so
this is also interesting vivec is
answering this saying this is not vital
but we have to be able to make sure that
we are energy independent so we are not
reliant on countries like Russia when
they do these crazy things okay so this
is all good guys we are now seeing
diverse political thought amongst these
people uh here is South Dakota governor
uh Kirsty gnome she says the primary
external threat to the United States is
communist China our opposition to Russia
has heightened this threat for a number
of reasons okay so that's interesting
too she doesn't fully comment on what's
going on with Ukraine I'm sure she has
her reasons
but she's aiming this more at China and
we do have a massive China problem that
seemingly is always seemingly is going
to get worse over the next couple years
and just to be clear a couple uh GOP
Presidential hopefuls did not respond
that includes Nikki Haley Mike Pompeo
ASA Hutchinson Ambassador John Bolton
and Governor Chris sununu so this is
good stuff
but I missed one guy there didn't I I
missed that Ron DeSantis and this is one
of the things that people are trying to
hit the Santa song oh you've been
governor of Florida you can handle the
beaches and the Sunshine and all that
stuff but what is your foreign policy
chops what are what are your foreign
policy beliefs well here Tucker I'm
going to let Tucker do it himself uh he
read Governor desantis's full statement
on Ukraine with some commentary take a
look
and then maybe the most newsworthy
response that we received was from
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis DeSantis
has well-known views on many topics of
course but until tonight no one could
really say with Precision where he stood
on the war in Ukraine which is arguably
the most important topic in the world
and now we know
DeSantis is adamantly opposed the
position that most Republicans in
Washington have taken on Ukraine
DeSantis is not a neocon who knew quote
well the U.S has many vital national
interests to santis rights securing our
borders addressing the crisis of
Readiness within our military achieving
energy security and Independence and
checking the economic cultural and
military power of the Chinese Communist
Party becoming further entangled in a
territorial dispute between Ukraine and
Russia is not one of them
without question he writes peace should
be the objective the U.S should not
provide assistance that could require
the deployment of American troops or
enable Ukraine to engage in offensive
operations Beyond its borders f-16s and
long-range missiles should therefore be
off the table these moves would risk
explicitly drawing the United States
into the conflict and drawing us closer
to a hot war between the world's two
largest nuclear powers that risk is
unacceptable
the sentence goes on to oppose the
policy of regime change in Moscow which
is very popular in Washington and he
points out that the bite Administration
has created an alliance between Russia
and China and that's a disaster for the
United States
so that's
desantis's position
clarified
before we get to the nitty-gritty on
desantis's position what's most
interesting about this is you have to
understand Tucker Carlson is mostly an
isolationist I don't want to speak
exactly for him but but he's more along
the lines of we should be caring about
Americans we should be caring about the
Heartland we should be funding things so
that people in America can prosper the
most that's that's that's really I would
say Tucker's uh reason for being a
public figure that is what he cares
about that's what he's written about and
talks about all the time uh and what
he's in essence saying the reason he
read that one the way he did is hey this
guy is not a neocon he doesn't want to
get us in these crazy Wars what I also
liked about desantis's commentary there
it was the most detailed do not give
them certain weapons that could go on
the offense what have I been saying this
entire time throughout the Ukraine war
every week we give them more money we
give them more weapons and and you can
see guys like Lindsey Graham and Mitch
McConnell well this will help just turn
the tide of the war this will do it and
it's like no it's not oh we gave them
four more tanks they got a couple more
planes a little more cash that we don't
know what they're doing with none of
this has ended the war it has elongated
the war it has gotten us into a
protracted conflict that nobody knows
how it's going to end except the crazy
guy on the other side of the world does
have the biggest bomb and he has quite a
few of them and that is a problem so
DeSantis is trying to give a somewhat
measured answer there now you might like
Trump's just sort of like completely
blanket they I you know I was thought of
as crazy so they weren't going to do
anything under me and that might be the
best policy but I think you what you see
here is some political diversity of
thought and that is good and by the way
whether you like Trump or DeSantis or
Nikki Haley or vivec or whoever you like
or whether you like none of those people
the fact that this is happening now this
is really good because it's going to
make the media not know what to do about
it the Democrats clearly are going to be
the party of War this this Democrat
machine
the Biden Michigan the money laundering
that's going on in Ukraine and all that
stuff it cannot stop itself so they're
the party of War so whoever ends up
doing this on the Republican side will
be more anti-war and that I think
ultimately is a good thing so now let's
get this thing full circle to where we
started with the show we started with
Bill Maher right and Bill Maher
basically was saying well you know
DeSantis is just going to be a retread
of trump and who wants that retread
except the thing is he has done the
things that have caused the place where
he governs to flourish and you may
remember this we've played it a couple
times but I thought it was worth bearing
repeating on today's show which I will
send to Bill myself even bill
has admitted I got him to admit it I
could put a little feather in my cap on
this one even Bill Maher has admitted
that there is a way he himself would
move to the scary Red State of Florida
and it's because of the lunacy of
California and big government and Gavin
Newsom and Democrat policies
if California yeah says I have to take
shots
and just said just says I don't
hello Florida
that's what I'll say about DeSantis
he's a good dude he's a good dude
he really is and he doesn't care whether
you smoke weed and he doesn't care who
you marry just he doesn't but to sound
like the uh
voiceover and a movie that's coming out
soon
just got real
but like for me personally really
just got real with that yeah and that's
that's in my mind I left this place
because of it and I don't want to leave
the leave this place that it would be
very hard I'm 66 years old I know I look
40. look amazing the hair seems thicker
than it was years a couple years ago I
don't know what your dentist
he was not easy but it's not easy for
anyone right
I'm playing that clip again is because
it sounds like Mars going to go the
other way right like so trust me in Mars
mind he wants he wants Trump to be the
nominee because it will make it very
easy for him to say I'm still the
liberal and the Republicans are all
bananas DeSantis really complicates this
for a lot of people that's why the
machine is going nuts because the good
liberals realize that freedom actually
matters Classical liberalism
I used to talk about it quite often is
is the most freedom-based ideology that
there is and if you are a classical
liberal meaning you believe in old
school individual rights you believe in
laissez-faire economics you believe that
people should make choices for
themselves and associate with the people
who they want to associate with and you
believe in limited government and all of
those Notions well then in essence you
are a moderate Republican right now and
I believe that is what most of us are so
DeSantis is the threat to the people on
the fringes because he's the one that
can bring this stuff together I sense it
could be a Reagan you know 1984 kind of
situation but we shall see I enjoyed
today's program
you will all have lunch and then be sent
off to live your lives that's what we
shall do today but if you want to join
us for the post game show coming up in
under 60 seconds you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview it's blowing up on the
computer machine with Russell Brand is
up on YouTube and Rumble it's up of
course the full thing ad free over on
locals uh and since we we hit Corinne
Jean-Pierre pretty hard today here's her
predecessor Jen saki with the cold
clothes and then I'll see you in the
post game in just a couple minutes and
we'll see everybody else tomorrow
I have to Circle back on that one
that's an excellent question I don't
have any information on it in front of
me but I'll Circle back with you if
there's more to convey to which I'm
happy to Circle back with you I'm happy
to Circle back with our team on that
specific report I'll have to Circle back
with you on it's a good question but uh
we will Circle back with you if there's
more to to update you on on that but
we'll Circle back with you on this today
uh we'll Circle back with you we will
certainly Circle back with you more
directly so I can Circle back with our
covet team and see if we have more
specifics I'll have to check on that
specific piece and we'll Circle back
with you directly I can I'll Circle back
if there's more I can share with you I
often note I'm going to circle back I
hate to disappoint conservative Twitter
but I am going to circle back on a
number of things as we often do directly
I will venture to do that and circle
back with you direct
thank you everyone happy Friday
[Music]
thank you